hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand final of the magnus cause in
chester and we are in the finals of the
grand final of the magnus calls in chess
tour now
i've been getting a lot of messages that
you guys prefer the old setup but as i'm
on vacation now it's impossible for me
to have my old setup here
since i'm not at home uh so this is the
setup that we will be having until the
21st of august until i return home
now before we check out the game which
is uh which is really awesome but
there's something uh well not i'm not
going to say
even greater but almost as great
happening
at this exact same moment again is uh
doing a live stream where he's saying
captures captures 100 000 times so
first thing you'll see in the
description below is the link to the
live stream uh say hello to
madrid and wish him luck on his quest to
achieve 100 000 captures
uh now let's get uh uh straight into the
game so this is magnus versus hicaro
first game ended in a draw this is the
second game where magnus has the white
pieces
of their first match and remember the
finals is the best of
seven uh so seven matches we'll see who
takes uh
home uh everything so magnus with the
white pieces opens with
d4 with knight of six by hikaru c c4 e6
and knight to f3 with d5 uh the queen's
gambit declined is on the board
uh sorry let me just bring the mic a
little bit closer there we go
uh and knight the c3 uh we have d
captures on c4 e4
and now b5 so this is the vienna
variation we have e5 challenging the
knight and
now something uh very interesting knight
to d5 and knight
captures on b5 and here knight to b6 the
only move ever played here
guarding the c4 pawn uh and here we have
a3
and this is a new move in the position
uh this position has been reached quite
a few times bishop to e2 is uh
is the idea uh that was played like
uh most of the times but a3 is a new
move so already as of move uh
uh seven we have a completely new game
so let's see how hikaru deals with this
uh with knights to c6 he continues
development with bishop the e3
developing while defending and knights
to a5 now hikaru preparing to bring the
knight over to
b3 with queen to c2 by magnus and now
a6 uh challenging the knight pushing it
back knight to c3
and now bishop to e7 uh of course
they're preparing the castle so
rook to d1 and now bishop to b7 by
hikaru uh just
continuing development bishop to e2 by
magnus and queen to d7 sing
okay maybe i'll castle king side maybe
i'll castle queen side we'll we'll see
how it goes
uh and magnus goes h4 saying that i'm
i'm inviting you to castle king side i
have h5 h6 and
i can play rogue h3 the g3 and bring the
rook into the game
so a lot of possibilities here and my
king is still on e1 maybe i'll just play
king f1 maybe i will castle who knows
what might happen
so bishop to c6 by hikaru preparing to
trade some pieces off with bishop
to a4 here and magnus goes for rook to
h3 preparing rook
g3 to go after the g7 pawn
so rook the b8 by hikaru he plans to
open up the b
file and then put some pressure not on
the queen it's a weird uh
ever since success.com updated their
interface you can do the weirdest errors
possible like what's what what is this
like how can rook do these errors but it
is possible
uh but okay rook g3 by magnus and now
bishop to a4 challenging the queen and
here magnus trades we have characters
and captures
and now you don't have time to grab here
since the queen is hanging so you have
to do something about that
and even if you like trade like this you
still can't capture because there's
characters on b2
and white doesn't really gain anything
so after queen captures an a4 we have
rook to c1 defending the queen and only
now knight b3 by hikar hikaru getting
that knight to an excellent square
and here magnus could play the passive
rook to d1 uh which is
probably the way to go but he prefers to
go uh actively and he goes to rook
captain g7
uh the result in the match is still uh
nothing the only
first game was a draw so uh there is
room to you know for some creativity so
the rook captures and g7
magnus sacrifices the exchange so knight
characters on c1 hikaru accepts
queen captures on c1 and now c3 hikaru
continues in the greatest of styles
saying that either you will capture here
and allow me this uh
picking up of the a3 pawn which also
gives me a past
a three pawn or you're gonna capture
with the queen so you you you get a pawn
but now knight to d5 i get
uh uh completely uh do whatever
whatever i want so queen c1 and now
knight captures an e3
f captures an e3 you have to keep an eye
on the b2 pawn so f captures
and now king to f8 by hikaru pushing the
rogue back we have rook to g4
now aligning the rook kind of with the
queen along the fourth rank so maybe
some
d5 ideas will be possible in the future
if the rook will be it will be defended
but hikaru just goes queen to b3 he puts
pressure on the b
two pawn he's of the exchange so he
would very much like to trade pawns
but now comes queen cactus on c7 by
magnus and queen catchers on b2
and here's the moment where the magic uh
well
almost happens here magnus plays king to
f2 he wants to get his king to a safer
square
but the d5 was really just a beautiful
move here
d5 threatening d6 if you get d6 in it's
basically resigns for black
so black would have to capture here and
now e6 poses so many problems for black
that it's
uh it's simply unreal because whatever
you do
let's say you try f6 or f5 doesn't
really matter uh for example f5 rook g7
wow uh just incredible stuff uh because
if king captures then this is just
checkmate
king g8 and queen to f7 checkmate and
if you don't you can even capture with
the queen otherwise you're getting mated
here
uh so if you capture with the queen just
queen captures here now the queen no
longer guards the rook
bishop uh blocks and queen just checked
so it would be it would be a terrible
uh thing to happen to black however
magnus first uh wanted to prepare the
move with king to f2
but now hikaru no longer allows the
fight he carry me to immediately goes
for queen to b7 he offers a queen trade
magnus of course declines with queen to
f a5 but now rook g8
not allowing any sneaky ideas so rook to
f4 by magnus
still hoping to get some uh some tricks
in there maybe maybe knight g5
or knight e6 is coming as the f pawn is
pinned uh
a lot of possibilities here but now
queen c6 by hicaru
uh preparing to drop that rook uh into
the game with queen to d2 magnus stops
it
and now h6 by hikaru taking away the g5
square from carlson's knight
queen to d3 now uh you could have
captured this a6 pawn already but now
uh as he carl played everything
correctly now magnus probably will go
for this maybe some e4 d5
ideas are possible but this this seems
to be a much safer choice
so rogue g7 by hikaru and now magnus
goes for it queen captures we have queen
captures bishop characters and
now rook to b2 with check bishop to e2
blocking and
now bishop captures an a3 so no pass
once on the queen side for magnus
and now that everything has been said
and done it's uh two rooks for hikaru uh
and a bishop and the knight against the
rook for magnus so
uh really sorry now there's a knight a
knight uh for a rook for magnus so
he carved up the exchange but magnus up
two pawns and
it is a it is a double e pawn but okay
carlson pushes g4
and we have bishop back to e7 by hikar
not allowing any pawn pushes and here
rook the e4 by magnus rook to e4
probably
probably waiting to see what uh hikar
will do
as you don't really have all that many
pawn pushes left so here rook g8 hikaru
prepares to bring the king into the game
rook f4 magnus repeats and now king to
g7
so what what can you do now uh carlton
starts with the g5
so he he trades some some pawns off h
captures knife captures we have bishop
captures and h captures
but now uh you will see that this isn't
the greatest possible
uh idea for magnus as uh now magnus has
a lost position
uh he allowed hikaru too much now feel
free to pause the video here and find
the winning move for hikaru
while i give you a couple of seconds
characters captures so uh for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations on spotting that that
bishop and king are very very
awkwardly placed and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to hate the threat of course is
rook h2 check followed by rook captures
an e2 game over
so magnus needs to do something about
this he tries king of three
not allowing this check to come with
captures but
rook to h3 check just the same king g4
and now rook captures an e3 if you go if
you go back then just
check and you also just lose the bishop
not not much you can do here
and if you try attacking this guy here
then just root characters on e3 this is
now pinned
not much you can do so after rookie
three magnus stride rook g4 now comes to
rook characters on e3 and now it's
already incredibly dangerous now magnus
is only
up one pawn for the sacrificed exchange
so bishop f3 but now rook d2 how do you
defend this pawn as the other rook is
coming also here
well uh he will have to try something
king h4 now rook ev3
now there's no saving this pawn it's on
a dark square so magnus just pushes it
uh at least he will create some
weaknesses so
he captures on v5 and now rook to f6 by
magnus
rook to e3 going after this pawn and now
rook to f5
not allowing magnus to create any any
ideas with let's say pushing the pawn
and then something like that so now
this rook is stuck guarding the pawns
here and there's not much you can do
rook to be for czech by hikaru and now
king h5 and now
a brilliant move by hikaru rook to b4
putting magnus in a complete soup swung
you cannot move this rook as these pawns
will fall you can't really move the king
anywhere
it's the king would be in check and most
of all if you move the bishop just rook
h3
will be checkmate so it completes luke's
one for magnus
he tries e6 as there is no other move uh
so
f captures on e6 and now rook to f6 but
now
the position is uh very very much lost
rook to e5 by hikaru and now rook g6
check a few more checks king f7 rook f6
check king to uh e7 and now king h6 now
magnus is hoping to push his passport to
victory
but hikaru says i'm very much ready for
that rook v8 we have rook to f4
now preparing to put the rook behind the
past pawn rook the f8 of course uh
offering a trade here and now you don't
have to
you have a chance to put a room behind a
patch pawn because the bishop would be
hanging so here magnus straight
captures captures g6 hoping for
something like this
check and queen but hikaru of course
plays king to g8 and
there is not much for magnus to do
magnus played king to g7
but now he carries just played rook to
e1 and it was
in this position that magnus carlsen
resigned the game
and game two goes to hikaru so the first
victory of the match is hikaru over
magnus with the black pieces in
in game two of their first match so here
you resign because
black can do pretty much anything you
can either pick up the pawn with the
disc or you can just push this pawn to
victory and it is a game over there is
no way to
promote the spawn there is no way to
check the black king like all of these
scores are covered you don't have
something like check and
uh queening and all of these squares are
covered so you don't have something like
this
there's just no no possible way to do
this and this is much too slow for
example to sacrifice the bishop this and
this
uh the rule can easily kick the king
away and you're not getting anything
so yeah game two of the match goes to
hikaru incredible stuff and like i said
do check out the live stream again
motorino going for captures captures
100 000 times is the first link in the
description below give him your support
and
let's see if if this is even possible so
that's uh the game i do hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank you
sukhoi david kimura adam grippo martin
aldean and omar hafiz for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the magnus
carlsen uh grand final checking up on
your one of suggestions and whatever
else happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and a special
announcement is coming at 100 000
captures
see you soon